boniface winnipeg
james bays a d'abord étudié les sciences
à l'université du manitoba avant de
devenir professeur émérite à la
prestigieuse université princeton new
jersey est franchement plusieurs
considèrent james peebles comme le père
de la cosmologie moderne
en raison de ces travaux sur les débuts
de l'univers notamment des modèles
décrivent le big bang ce qu'on appelle
le bruit de fond cosmologique
il a été un des premiers à faire cette
prédiction qui devait y avoir un résidu
des premières phases de l'évolution de
l'univers les recherches de peebles
aussi permis de mieux comprendre la
constitution de l'univers avec les
concepts de la matière noire et de
l'énergie sombre vous et moi tout ce qui
nous entoure en effet de ce qu'on
appelle de la matière ordinaire donc des
protons et neutrons des électrons les
étoiles et galaxies et on s'est rendu
compte que ça correspond à seulement 4 %
de tout ce qui existe dans l'univers
il ne reste 96% du cosmos à découvrir et
jean guilbault a fait des contributions
dans ce domaine
monsieur peebles et co récipiendaire
beck un duo de scientifiques suisses
récompensé pour la découverte de la
toute première exoplanète
les trois lauréats recevront leur prix
nobel de physique ainsi que l'équivalent
de 1,2 million de dollars canadiens lors
de la cérémonie qui aura lieu le 10
décembre prochain à stockholm en suède
ici julie et mon radio canada laval